this morning voter uh Fox voter analysis
revealing immigration the top issue
again like Iowa for New Hampshire voters
just like uh we told you last week
Donald Trump assuring voters he feels
the same
way you take a look at our border so bad
there's never been a border like this in
the
world four years ago we had the safest
best Border in the United States I built
hundreds of miles of border
wall well our next guest was at last
night rally Fox News contributor and
retired acting ice director Tom homman
joins us now Tom good morning good
morning last night you said you worked
for six presidents he was the best when
it came to securing the border now this
is an issue for the Democrats why is
that well look for a couple reasons I
think I think Governor Abbott and Dan
santis did a great thing by sending
illegal aliens to Sanctuary cities that
caused Democrat Mayors and Democrat
Governors to speak up but I also give a
lot of credit to Fox News you guys
stayed on the story you guys stayed on
the story from day one you got you can't
deny Bill malan's videos right you can
say the board secure all you want you
can't deny what Griff Jenkins shows you
so I think Fox News deserves a lot of
credit for telling American people the
truth probably be a part of the network
and Joe Biden for actually breaking the
Border worse than any other president
ever to the point where he even admitted
uh it's a crisis but he wants more money
he says give me money what does money do
this isn't a money issue it's a policy
issue he could change the policies
tomorrow put the remain in Mexico prog
program back in tomorrow the highest
court of land sent is legal to be a game
changer put the third safe country
agreements back in place that he
abolished that's a game changer those
two things alone would solve 85 90% of
your profit right if if there was a
policy where you come across the river
we're going to turn you around they
wouldn't come across the river it's that
simple and even though we're in New
Hampshire and you're absolutely right
we've been covering this issue for 20
years here on the Fox News Channel and
it was Greg Abbott who who started
busting people to the big cities the big
media towns and suddenly it's a big
issue in the Big Towns we're all talking
about it and that's one of the reason
reasons yesterday when I went out and I
talked to some of the voters about 5
miles away from here at the Bedford High
School their number one issue and it
wasn't just Republicans it was also
Democrats and it was undecided and it's
the migration it's those people coming
across the river watch what they had to
say
yesterday can I ask you who you voted
for yes for Donald Trump for Donald
Trump yeah why uh why
Trump I'll tell you I'm an ex immigrant
I'm United States citizen
my son is a military my brother-in-law
is a
military and uh I think I get along with
whatever he has planned to for the
United States I was in out of this
country and they don't think too well
about United States I want this country
to go back and be proud of what we are
because I think a lot of people they
come here because they expect something
they expect the hope and
he could he could give this all back to
people and you know Tom what I heard
from people was they don't want to just
make America great again they want to
make America safe again right you know
last night when I made the comment I
work for six presidents I didn't finish
the statement because oford that nothing
was planned about me going to you didn't
know he was going to call you up but
what I was trying to get to I work for
six presidents start with Ronald Reagan
and Donald Trump and every president did
something to secure the Border because
they understood you can't have National
Security on border security President
Biden's the first president in history
of this nation who unsecured border on
purpose right so it I wake up every day
angry because what he did to the most
secure Border in my lifetime I started
in Border to 1984 and the busting the
busing migrants to Sanctuary cities you
know who original ideal that was no
president Trump I remember sitting in
the Oval Office we're talking about
doing it great idea well you know why we
didn't do it because by the time the
plans got put together we couldn't fill
a bus to S of New York because it remain
in Mexico program the third safe country
agreements the policies were a game
changer this Administration can secure
the Border tomorrow if they wanted to
but they're not they want more money to
the line Pockets NOS put them in hotel
room in New York City 500 bucks a night
while thousands of empty ice beds are
sitting out there at about $127 night
already paid for by the taxpayers
sitting empty so Tom why do you think he
did it on purpose being that he's now
suffering politically because of it I
think he sold out to the progressive
elect to become president he sold out
but Joe Biden voted for this to secure
fence tax he voted for Border walls
first day as president he stopped
building them I think I think it's the
left I think there's two reasons I think
number one I think he sold out to the
progressive left to be president you got
to give him credit he kept his promises
he opened the board like he said he was
going to and second of all I think the
Democratic party the majority of them
think that they think there's a future
political benefit by letting millions of
people into this country know they say
they think they're future political
voters or Democratic voters maybe but I
think the issue is they don't have to
vote because what else did Biden do when
he signed 90 executive orders abolishing
everything we did he he changed a trump
census rule millions of more people will
be counted in senses in sanctuary cities
so repr proportionate seats in the House
more seats in the House for congress yes
or no are there terrorists in our
country because of this absolutely no
doubt about it well that was uh easy and
scary and and if Trump wins you're going
back how do you say you know the
president that gave us more secure
Border in my lifetime I've been doing
the Border since
1984 Tom thank you very much for joining
us on this than for S morning and your
son service too I appreciate it thank
you all right uh thanks Tom I'm Steve
duy I'm Brian kill me and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis